So TikTok is super overwhelming.
As much as I do like to make content and like,
to connect with people, it's.
I am also a normal person.
And so when, like,
magazines and, like,
news outlets reach out, I'm like,
so I stick my head in the sand a little bit and I hide a little bit,
which is what's currently happening,
and I'm trying to break out of it.
It's a game in my head. Um,
so I bought some plants, I bought some flowers,
and I'm posting this story,
but otherwise, that's where I've been.
I'm just been sticking my head in the sand and hiding
cause the attention. I'm like, okay,
let me just wait till it all dies down and then I'll talk again,
you know, which is not the best if you're like,
you know what I mean? Because this isn't like my job job.
This is something I do. Just.
It's like a public service.
My community service to the world
is just educating women to not sacrifice your whole
entire life and happiness
to have someone's children and cook their favorite fucking meals.
So anyway, that's where I've been.
I did post, um,
a podcast episode,
something about the instantness of TikTok.
That it's like, Boom,
Boom.
Gets overwhelming and then I, like,
start to hide. But anyway,
I did post a podcast episode further explaining my,
the red flags I see in the Ballerina Farms issue.
And yeah,
otherwise I'm having a Good weekend.
Look at all my gray hair. I kind of like it.
I'm into it. I got so many plants in my house.
I love it.
Okay. I hope you guys are well. I love you so much.